aux amateurs de sport d'anticipation à
l'amérique vient de livrer un étranger
hic le rhino il faut lever 75 kilomètres
à l'heure sur route et 22 600 tonnes
aborderez les espaces infinis du chaos
originel avec la même assurance
c'est votre dernier automobiles n'ont
pas exactement ceci est la première auto
modules pour vous quelle est la
différence entre une automobile et une
auto module bien écoutez je pense que
c'est très simple tout le monde peut le
voir une auto module c'est très beau et
une automobile
c'est très laid
une énorme sphère en plastique qui roule
sur les allées médusés les passants
devant cet engin mû par un homme qui
court à l'intérieur voyez comme ils
passent le bord du bassin sa plasticité
se joue des obstacles et bien sûr ils
flottent ballon et bulles son auteur l'a
appelé la ballue c'est magique on a
l'impression de marcher sur l'eau de
pouvoir s'élever au dessus des airs on
se dirige très très facilement ça s'est
très très bien très amusant